let's do another problem where we graph
a function based on the properties of
its derivatives and second derivative
and what's
especially interesting about this
problem i think is the fact that they
don't give the function they just give a
bunch of clues about the function so
what do they tell us
well they tell us that f of zero
f of zero
is equal to three
they also tell us
that f of three is equal to zero
f of three
is equal to zero
they tell us that f of six is equal to
four
f of six is equal to four
and what i like about this calculate
what i like about this problem is that
you can't use a calculator to solve it
because you don't know the function so
even if i gave you a graphing calculator
you'd be you'd be helpless
so anyway we could well let's let's
write down all the information then we
could we could plot it out
they also tell us let me write all the
derivative information here
they tell us that
f prime so the derivative
of x
is less than 0
on
the open interval
zero comma three so that means not
including zero and three
and they also tell us
that
the derivative
is greater than zero
on
the open interval from three comma six
so we can already guess that if we're
less than zero as we approach three and
we're greater than zero as we go away
from three that the derivative must be 0
at 3. that's that's the intuition
although they don't tell us they're for
sure but i'm assuming that this that
this function is continuous and
differentiable over all of the intervals
because they don't tell us otherwise
okay so that's the information tell us
about the first derivative
and what do they tell us about the
second derivative
they tell us that the second derivative
the second derivative
is greater than zero
on
the interval zero to five
right there's the open interval from
zero to five so that means it's concave
upwards there
and they also tell us that the second
derivative
is less than zero so it's concave
downwards
on
the open interval from five to six
so i don't know if they if well i don't
know you know they don't give us any
information what happens after six you
know maybe maybe it goes to an
inflection point we don't know so maybe
you know
we'll just assume that doesn't change so
what what does all this information tell
us well let's well first let's just
graph it
so f of 0 is 3 so we have to graph the
point 0 3
3 0 and 6 4. so it seems like all of the
action is in the first quadrant so i'll
graph it accordingly
so let me graph it
so this is i want to focus on the first
quadrant so that's my x-axis
that's my y-axis
let's see i have to go to 6-4
so let's see if this is
draw this so i want to draw this point
six four
so
one
two
three
four
five six
one
two
three
four
so that's the point six four
that's the point
six
comma four
and let's see three comma zero right so
that's one two three so that's this
point right here
that point right there is three comma
zero
three comma zero i got that from this
information and then we have the point
zero comma three 3
0 1 2 3 so this is 0 3
0 3. so those are the points that they
tell us that something well those are
definitely points on the function that's
what this tells us
and what do they tell us they tell us
that
the derivative is less than zero on the
interval from zero to three so from here
to here the derivative is less than zero
from here to here the derivative is less
than zero and that makes sense um
because we had to obviously decrease to
go from this value to this value but
what it does tell us is that the
function does not do something like this
the function does not do this
the function does not do that and how do
we know that well because if the
function moved up and then down
then
you'd have a positive slope here which
which this says is not possible right
the derivative is less than zero from
this interval to this interval so the
slope has to be negative the entire time
and then it tells us that the slope is
positive from 3
from this interval from x is equal to 3
to x is equal to 6 that's what this
tells us
and so you know the line has to look
something like that or like that
but it can't curve down and then go up
because if it curve down you'd have a
negative slope at some point it's okay
fair enough it's essentially the the
graph is monotonic from this point to
this point at this point to this point
and though
if you want to get technical the
monotonicity theorem tells us that well
then this this must be a point either
that is a
point where the derivative is zero or it
must be a point where there is no
derivative but i'm assuming that this
graph is differentiable over everything
and you know you didn't need the theorem
to tell you that we know that the slope
is less than zero as we approach here
in this interval we know the slope is
greater than zero on this interval and
if we assume that the derivative is
continuous which i will make that
assumption although they haven't told us
but in the absence of that information
why not
the if the derivative is always kind of
incrementing or decrementing at a
continuous rate the derivative must be
zero at this point right because it's
less than zero here and greater than
zero here so i'll draw a little
horizontal line to indicate that the
derivative is 0 there so it's going to
be a bit of a
it's going to be a bit of a minimum
point i think
and then let's move on to the
information on the second derivatives
and see what they're telling us
well they're saying that the second
derivative
is greater than zero from zero to five
so from zero to five
so this is five right here
from zero to five
so essentially that means what is this
what does this tell us this means that
we are concave upwards from zero to five
so concave upwards that gives us a lot
of information so that tells us
that not only are we monotonically
decreasing as we approach three
but we're concave upwards right and and
why is this concave upwards well as you
see the slope here is negative it's a
little less negative here i'll even less
negative here and then it slowly
approaches zero it gets less and less
negative and then it keeps increasing
until you get to five
right and then from five to six
from five to six what happens the second
derivative becomes negative so we enter
a point that is concave downwards so
from five to six i don't know what the
value of the function is at five
but from five to six the function let me
pick a suitably different color becomes
concave downwards from x equals five to
x equals six
so becomes concave downwards so f of
five we don't know what f of 5 is but f
of 5 didn't tell us is an inflection
point
that's where we went from going concave
upwards to concave downwards
and i think that's all we can do with
this graph we don't know what happens i
mean actually we made a couple of
assumptions anyway that the graph is
continuous and differentiable over the
whole thing but anyway i think this will
give you an intuition on on what all of
this you know first and second
derivative and all of this stuff does
for us and you know just so you know as
if this was an inflection point they
could have told us that
f prime prime of 5 is equal to 0. we
don't know that for sure but i'm just
assuming it anyway hopefully you hope
you found that
vaguely
vaguely useful actually since i have
time let me do one more bonus problem
that that
that i was sent
and it was it was written right after
that problem so why not do it and it
says prove that a quadratic function has
no inflections what does a quadratic
function look like
f of x is equal to a
x squared plus b x plus c
it says prove that this has no
inflection point well what's an
inflection point it's a point where the
second derivative is equal to zero
so let's figure out the second
derivative is
the first derivative
of a quadratic of this quadratic but a
quadratic can be written like this
is two
a x plus b
and what's the second derivative
well that's just equal to 2a
now an inflection point is when the
second derivative is equal to 0.
now my question to you is
can
this
function ever equals zero
well the only way that this function
would equal zero if some for some reason
a was zero but if a was zero then it
wouldn't be a quadratic because then it
would this term wouldn't exist it would
be b x plus c it would be just a line
so if we're talking about a quadratic
where this a coefficient is non-zero
which it has to be because that's the
coefficient of the x term
there's no way that this if this if a is
non-zero there's no way that this
function this expression is non-zero so
there's no way that the second
derivative can ever be zero and thus
we have proved that a quadratic has no
point of inflection
see you in the next video